عندما تتحدث الولايات المتحده يعني نقلا
عن اكسيوس نقلا عن مسؤولين امريكيين بانها
لم تبلغ الولايات المتحده
مسبقا بهذه العمليه وان ايضا جهه
اسرائيليه تضيف بانها بلغتها يعني اسرائيل
ابلغت واشنطن اثناء تنفيذ
العمليه لماذا برايك مثل هذا
النائي الاسرائيلي مثلا عن ابلاغ الولايات
المتحده ترك هذه
مسافه لاسرائيل ام ترك هذه المسافه
للولايات المتحده من هذه الخطوه الاقدام
عليها ومن
تداعياتها السب الرئيس سلمى ان هناك موقف
امريكي معلن منذ بدء الحرب على قطاع غزه
يقوم على عدم توسيع نطاق الحرب وكانت هناك
تحضيرات امريكيه واضحه وصريحه سواء
الايران او حزب الله عبر وسطاء بعدم توسيع
نطاق الحرب في قطاع غزه ايضا كان هناك
ارسال
ل سفن حربيه وحمله طيارات يو اس جيرال
فورد التي تسمى سحبها بالامس من المنطقه
وبالتالي هناك موقف امريكي ثابت مع عدم
توسع نطاق الحرب حتى لا تتورط فيها امريكا
لكن ايضا انا اعتقد ان هذه العمليه قد
يكون هناك نوع من التفهم الامريكي لها
لعده اعتبارات الاعتبار الاول انه نتحدث
عن شخصيه هي بحد ذاتها مطلوبه امريكيا
هناك رصد مكافاه 5 مليون دولار لمن يبلغ
عن صالح العرور نتيجه لتور توتي حسب
امريكا في عمليات اختيال وعمليات في الضفه
الغربيه في 2015 اخص عمل 2014 نتج عنها
قتل
ثلاثه ثلاثه صبيا اسرائيليين من ضمنهم
صبيح من الجنسيه الامريكيه وبالتالي هناك
شبه اتفاق امريكي اسرائيلي على هذه
المساله الامر الاخر المهم جدا انه
التفاهم الامريكي قد ياتي في اطار نوع من
الصفقه نوع من الاتفاق الضمني بين اسرائيل
واداره بايدن يقوم على تخفيض العمليه
العسكريه البريه في قطاع غزه مقابل القيام
بعمليات تطلق عليها سيرجيكال اوبريشن او
تارد اوبريشن عمليات نوعيه ت تستهدف
قيادات معينه في حركه حماس سواء قيادات
عسكريه و قيادات سياسيه الامر الثالث
المهم ان هذه العمليه تعيد نوعا من الهيبه
ترمم صوره اسرائيل ومن خلفها امريكا بان
هناك هيبه اقليميه لاسرائيل وامريكا فيما
يتعلق باستهداف قط المقاومه ال فلسطينيه
خاصه خارج الاراضي الفلسطينيه وبالتالي
هذه العمليه رغم يعني حتى هذه اللحظه ليس
هناك موقف رسمي او بيان رسمي في هذه
المساله هناك تسريبات من هنا وهناك
لمسؤولين الامريكيين انه ليس هناك علم
مسبق لكن هناك اختار اثناء تنفيذ العمليه
لكن بشكل عام اتوقع وجود نوع من التفهم
الامريكي لهذه العمليه خس كما قلت قبل
قليل انها تستهدف اولا رمز فلسطيني ليس
رمز لبناني وبالتالي من الصعب توقع وجود
يعني تصعيد كبير فيما يتعلق بهذه الحرب قد
يكون تصعيد محدود نوعا ما لكن بشكل عام
هناك على ما يبدو حسابات دقيقه لهذه
المساله لن تسفر عن توسع للطاق الحرب في
ظني قد تؤدي الى وجود بعض الاشتبكات
المتصاعده نوع ما لكنها ليست حرب شامله
كما يرغب بعض الاطراف داخل اسرائيل لكن
بشكل عام هناك في رايي تفهم امريكا لهه
المساله ن تيجي لكل هذه العوامل التي
ذكرتها قبل قليل اها